lancement de ces squeeze aujourd'hui on
se trouve sur sonic en fer qui fait bien
évidemment partie de cette fameuse
catégorie de jeu rage en commun de faire
mario kart mario et cetera donc je ne
sais pas pourquoi je fais une vidéo sur
ça mais bon on y va pakula holla holla
leçon tu vas te calmer on sent encore
être des pièges deux ans je suis surpris
le panier n'est pas un piège attention
et du progrès quand même cette fleur est
un piège oui est-ce pas mal à ce qu'on a
fait on pourrait se contenter de ça sans
déconner à sa marge à metz avoir jamais
ben oui c'est moi ou il ya là la musique
en mille fois up non bah oui mais je
suis bête mois où on met deux fois de
suite ou lui qu'est ce qui t'arrive la
fonte fer peuvent sauter direct aux
cardons et s'échappe du piège saleh aux
acteurs professionnels de scènes
dramatiques depuis 2002 way up au regard
des os sont dégoûtés ça c'est un piège
ça c'est pas un piège ce trampoline
n'était pas un piège suis très étonné
déjà up
oh [ __ ] tous os 2
c'était génial ce qu'on a fait là il y
avait un feeling à 20 rythme hop hop
non ah ah ah ah ah ah non mais pourquoi
je suis celano je vois heroes il tourne
sur lui-même cheveux romano c'est très
stressant
or on sort les steaks on n'a pas le
temps haha on aurait dû prendre le temps
finalement mesdames et la fleur la fleur
rose est là pour toi lui louait depuis
quand je m'appelle lulu pas les pit la
fleur rose ok on est bon poss allez on
est mort 11 fois dans le premier niveau
c'est pas mal
acte 2 bonjour acte 2 ah oui d'accord au
revoir à que la violence mais d'entrée
de jeu oh j'ai raté mon saut mais
regardez pas
or voilà la doublette j'ai esquivé le
problème est le deuxième dans un peu
trop haut fourbe on n'a plus la musique
mais merde up alone et olam et troisième
actes à revoilà la musique voilà ça me
faisait en fait que n'a pas la musique
vous avez vu j'inscris l'incroyable donc
j'ai pas niveau sur ce jeu c'est
entièrement à cause de la musique en
voilà et je cherche pas d'excusés mais
regardez pas comme ça au delà ces
poissons masse perd pas trop confiance
aux plats bah ouais mais pour qui vous
prenez vous allez vous faire péché aller
pêcher lp chaud
ababou l'epic là faut sauter direct
parce que c'est clos a annonc
salut je vais faire avec vos poissons de
cette mauvaise idée salut j'ai voulu
faire bouger aux pressions mais c'est
très mauvaise idée mais ce mardi
toutefois ce à quoi je fais tuer par une
carpe qui il quoi de plus humiliant sur
l'icône et j'en étais sûr ce n'est pas
possible
agdam on crie on sentait la fébrilité à
sion de tes dents de poissons oeufs
deuxième wii et battant et bhl et je
fais un spectacle ils sont bien coller
faudra avoir un timing très serré
[ __ ] mais je voulais mettre une femme
pour que le tout s'apaise puis les pays
qu'on fait on est là on sera sauvé la
distance a suffi à mal à vous voyez par
exemple avec ces poissons s'est pas du
tout arrangée
[Musique]
j'étais fébrile j'étais fébrile poisson
un poisson à pic
ok mais là c'est très dur franchement
[Musique]
on est bien on est bien on est bien on
est bien banny tupou compagnie creux en
eau et la note anne où aller et je suis
mort 25 foy où là les cas vandales
avaient tous abbaoui des pics aussi bien
sûr qu'est ce qui fait le plus peur de
la halle à bout des pays-bas dépit des
cure dents on aime au nom alors on
remarquera c'est plus des poissons mais
il faut exactement le même mouvement ça
je tiens à dire c'est scandaleux à ça
fait mal d'amis se confondent avec les
piliers regarder la même couleur la même
forme pas du tout mais ça vous fait elle
trouve une excuse
bîmes à la tête le les fesses de boules
de feu c'était impressionnant je savais
je savais ah ah ah ah tiens il y en a un
des deux qui piègent soit le premier
cuves en béton soit lherm soit le
deuxième
là il nous indique en erreur faut aller
direct sur le sur la verdure bah oui et
là aussi je pense qu'il ya un piège faut
aller direct loi
[Musique]
ce bal en caisse pour saab de ce carnage
oh oh oh oh mon dieu telle chose mais
elle impute à wow [ __ ] je suppose que
ça ok à des pics là dessus je préfère
analyser le terrain ok à l'epic là
dessus je préfère d'azé le terrain est
franchement là on a un doigté vrai os
est choquant j'aimerais à webb a bien
sûr hockey doit avoir un cube caché
quelque part dans l'espace temps ok
j'avais encore rien dit rien mais ce
millimètre
là il chausse du 46 chaussée du 42e
c'était pas bon il tombait dans la lave
soif ou sauter très loin s'en faut pas
sauter très loin on va sauter très loin
se trouve c'est juste là non ce qui peut
pas sortir une rame de barques
résistante à la laver et se met à faire
ça comme ça pour qu'on avance
oh c'est bon ah mais c'est évident
regarder les là il est sur son trône ce
petit trampoline 3 qui ment parce qu'il
est roi se trompe olivier leroy je suis
sur celui en droit de c'est un piège
poil en dessous non pas dans la lave non
plus honni tarn élections on ne résiste
pas à la lave je crois tu vois mieux ou
pis tu résistes arrière à led sonic pas
perfection au cette fin elle fait
remarquer à l'acte iii je veux finir ce
jeu pas besoin de culmont gare au
travers ce besoin là tu besoin de rien
envie d'un cube
bah oui bah laisse-moi crevé dans la
lave ah ben oui on allait se promènent
6-1 pas là il n la lave a au nom
j'aurais dû la trappe et à ce moment là
voilà c'est parti pour une ligne
d'attentats tard et à force de glisser
sur ma chaise cette création est en
string là j'en ai marre et voilà j'ai
arrêté mon cul à cause de ce 4 son
chouchou
[Musique]
on est innocent monsieur ne pas perdre
nous finirons ce jeu baa que s'est il
passé
je ne sais pas tout est trop bête
puisque ce jeu a été développé dans un
garage r&d obligé de le rater voilà auto
temps autant retourner sur celui là pour
lui dire bonjour au salut ça va
j'aurais pas dû être gentil avec ce
deuxième cubes alors là c'est un piège
lui un jet reconnaît mois les
trampolines avec un pic ils sont un peu
plus un peu plus courbé comme ça voire
même un peu comme
j'en peux plus c'est un effet sur le
cerveau et je vais faire comme ça c'est
dingue tout se passera bien lui ça c'est
un piège le sens on va y aller quand
même
bah ouais parce qu'on est con non n'en
reviendra reviendra aux haies on avait
tout un mouvement circulaire ça ça doit
être une maladie quoi la géométrisation
[Musique]
howie zone finale non on va finir un
jeune faire presser entrées et l'on va
avoir des trucs par 3 août
jo était sûr maintenant ben voilà belle
technique vient la cub on a pu terminer
des poissons qui résiste à la maintenant
des magmas poissons et ben voilà que toi
tu résistes pas là lavedan banon away et
ben amor aulas c'est quoi ça mais non
mais je refuse ok j'ai j'en étais sûr au
moment où j'ai sauté j'ai vu dans
l'avenir et j'ai vu qu'une boule
l'option de chips blanche allait venir
me quoi vous croyez pas en mon talent de
médium c'est ça oh
alors ça c'est est ce qu'il est ben oui
mon grand poisson watts
on a vu on a vu le méchant on l'a vu
réaction c'est une sur deux petites
victoires
on y va on n'a pas le temps on y va on
n'a pas le temps on n'y va pas on n'est
pas toi son boule de feu aubel steak
mais attendez à quel point mort quoi
regarder sans déconner on dirait qu'il
faisait une partie de pétanque qu'ils
ont déconné regarder scandaleux un mois
je suis scandalisée défendre
or on a tenté le move ce qu'il est mal à
terminer bien entre les dents du ba ba
ba
voilà moi j'aimerais une chaîne youtube
je l'appelais encore beat box et sam ait
fait le vide boxe en mode hardcore
bonjour au revoir
[Musique]
hélas bien cela le cube il a dit je
m'arrête ton dans la lave voilà je peux
continuer merci je suis scandalisé
devant temps 2 2 2 je ne terminera
jamais cette phrase on va y arriver
arrêtez de rage est comme ça c'est
énervant quoi human vs boules de plasma
mais à quel moment ils étirent à cette
hauteur au début il étire en bas
normalement et savez ce que c'est une
boule de feuilles c'est une rousse aux
cheveux longs goutte d'eau plus tard on
va y arriver on va y arriver à vrai dire
il faut prendre son temps et maintenant
mais c'est pour la lma il m'a donné quoi
un caillou félicitations vous avez
terminé le jeu merci d'avoir joué nombre
total de morts 2 en coop ça fait du bien
on a terminé un jeu à ne faire vous
rendez vous compte de ce que ça veut
dire [ __ ] ça veut dire que nous vivons
absolument pas changé en réalité on est
morts 22 fois voilà bon c'est bon tu
peux montrer la richesse voilà 225 x bon
ça va
il est temps d'arrêter de parler de cela
le jeu va carrément retourner savuth a
pas du tout mon corps merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo on se retrouve très
vite dans une prochaine tient tout le
monde pis
[Musique]